ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
aa5 กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่อง
คอมพรีเฮน Store ไทยนะครับให้ข้าโอเคอ้า
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันอะไรคะว่าจะให้มัน
อ่ะเปิดปฏิทินก่อนโอเคอ้าวันนี้วันนี้วัน
จันทร์ครับวันจันทร์เสื้อวันสีแดงภาพ
แดงวันจันทร์สีเหลืองนะผ้าวันนี้วัน
จันทร์วันจันทร์วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันจันทร์วันที่ 4 ครับวันที่ 4 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน
กรกฎาคมเบียน
กรกฎาคม
กับมะกฎาคมนี้วันอะไรเนี่ยวันนี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์ไงไม่ใช่ๆวันที่ 4
กรกฎาคมเอาอันนี้สิกและบาร์เป็นวันอะไร
อ๋อเป็นวันอ่ะวันชาติอเมริกามั้ยใช่มั้ย
ใช่ๆคือครูเอกจำได้อะไรนะจัดหนังๆใช่ไหม
hollywood
อีเลี่ยนเอเอสเจ
เล่นดูเหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะดูครับดูเขาตอน
นั้นอ่ะกลัวนี่ก็ยังออนอยู่นะกวนตีนเรียน
หนังสือทำงานจำไม่ได้แล้วยังเด็กๆใช่ไหม
ขออัดตีอย่างง่ายไปทำงานแล้วนะโอเคน่าจะ
เรียนหนังสืออยู่ผมจำ Will  Smith ได้นะ
โอเคแก้อ้าววันนี้วันที่ 4 ค่ะรึ
นอนระวังวาง
กรกฎาคมนะคะปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
2565 ครับ
มีข้อ 2 อะไรคะออนซ์ 2020
แต่ถ้า
แล้วตอนนี้เวลาตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงใช่ไหม
ครับ 5 นี่ครับตอนนี้เป็นตอนเย็นนะครับ
ค่ะตอนเย็นอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะดูนาฬิกา
4:00 น
16:00 น
50 น 5 นาที 4 โมง 55 นาทีนะคะๆเก๋
ๆเจอกับครู Arty ตอนยังไม่ดึกสักทีน่ะวัน
นี้วันนี้มาเร็วซะอย่างเอา
ธรรมดาเจอกันตอน 20:00 น 20:00 นน่าอะไร
ครับห่าวันนี้ขวดครูพูดสวัสดีเป็นครูนะ
รู้อะตี้จะพังอาร์นักเรียนกับครูเอ๋ไป
เที่ยวที่ไหนกันหาวันนี้อะอะพาไปเที่ยว
จังหวัดทางภาคอีสานเหมือนเดิมครับวันนี้
อ้าข้อควรที่อยู่พักอยู่อีสานมาอ่าหลายปี
สามปีชายชายประมาณ 4-5 ปี
เป็นคนใต้จะไปอีสานตายคนๆไหมอ่ะอ่า
ประจวบคีรีขันธ์ก็ยังไม่ตายนะเป็นอาจ
จังหวัดอะสุดท้ายจังหวัดสุดท้ายของภาค
ตะวันตกก่อนที่จะเป็นภาคใต้หอยังไม่ตายนะ
คะใช่ครับทั้งภาคใต้ภาคใต้จะเริ่มที่ทุ่ม
ขอนค่ะอ้าวประจวบคีรีขันธ์ยังเป็นภาค
ตะวันตก
พี่ก็ไม่พูดภาษาใต้เนาะอาไม่พูดกับพูดไม่
ได้ไม่ได้นะพ่อท่านเลยอีกหนึ่งจังหวัดนี่
คู่ได้แล้วภาษาตายแล้วนะคะ
แต่คนที่อยู่จังหวัดประจวบเหมือนครัวตี
เนี่ยคนที่อยู่แถวๆนะครับที่ติดกับชุมพร
ถ้าภาษาใต้ได้นะผู้ตายได้นะฮะหัวตี้อยู่
ไม่ติดกับชุมพรก็เลยพูดติดตั้งข้างบนใช่
ไหมคะได้วางอยู่ข้างบนข้างบนติดกับ
เพชรบุรีอ๋อก็คนเมืองเพชรนะ 555 ใช้ครับ
โอเควันนี้จะพาไปที่จังหวัด
อะไรคะจังหวัด
อุดรธานีครับปุ๊บเป็นอีสานเหนือๆอีสาน
อยู่ด้านเหนือขึ้นไปข่าวว่าสาวสวยมากฮ่าๆ
อุดรเมืองสาวสาวนะคะได้เล็กสาวอุดรก็คือ
พี่
ผู้หญิงอุดรเนี่ยอะไรไว้อ้าวโอเคถ้าถ้า
พูดถึงอุดรธานีถ้าพูดถึงอุดรธานีคู๋คิด
ถึงอะไรครับอุดรหรอ
อ่าจริงๆครูอัฐิบอกกูเองว่าน่ะเหรออะไร
ออกไปแล้วใช่มั้ยคือครูเอ๋น่ะบ่เคยไป
อุดรธานี
[เพลง]
คือไม่เคยไปอีสานเหนือ
ไม่ถึงเลยแต่ว่ามีชื่อเสียงที่สุดที่อุดร
เนี่ยนะจะมีสองอย่างไรคะอ่ะมีอะไร
อาทิตย์
จำได้นะคะอยากได้ก็คือ 1 ขยะนาคอ๋อ
ใช่ครับเพราะว่าอุดรธานีหยุดติดกับ
หนองคายหนองคายเพื่อจะติดกับแม่น้ำโขงก็
จะมีพญานาคพญานาคนะคะนักเรียนนะเดี๋ยวกู
จะพาไปดูนะคะอันนั้นที่ 1
พระไหมคะมีพระใช่ครับทางภาคอีสานจะมีพระ
ที่มีเสียงให้ครับหลายๆองค์ที่อุดรก็มี
อยู่องค์หนึ่งที่มีชื่อเสียงมากๆที่คนไทย
ทุกๆคนน่าจะรู้จักนะครับเป็นพระสงฆ์นะคะ
ให้ครับเป็นอ๋อนะครับพระสงฆ์อันนี้ครับ
อ้าอ่าฮะส่งรูปนี้น่ะ 3 เราพูดองค์มันจะ
พูดรูปนะก็พูดรูปก็ได้นะฮะชื่ออะไรนะคะ
โอเคอ่าเอารูปนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าหลวงตา
หลวงตาหลวงตาแปลว่าอายุมากถ่ายเค้าเป็น
พระที่แก่แล้วครับอายุเยอะๆน่ะๆอ้ะหลวงตา
มหาบัวครับหลวงตามหาบัว
ใช่ครับซับเสียงมากหลวงตามหาบัวเป็นพระ
ที่เก่งมากๆครับแล้วก็
เป็นอาจารย์ของกับพระอีกหลายๆคนใน
ปัจจุบันหน้าอีกหลายๆรูปในปัจจุบันก็
เป็นลูกศิษย์ของหลวงตามหาบัวอีกทีนึงอ่ะ
ครูอาชีพเป็นลูกศิษย์หลวงตามหาบัวด้วยไหม
คะกลัวตี้ไม่ได้เป็นลูกศิษย์สายตรงครับ
ไม่ได้เคยไปไปกราบหลวงตามหาบัวแต่ตอนที่
หลวงตายังอยู่ในครับอ่าวันนี้หลวงตาไม่
อยู่แล้วอ่ะหนูตาไม่อยู่แล้วก็ร่วมตาม
มรณภาพๆมรณภาพไปแล้วที่นักเรียนคะถ้าคน
น่ะคนเนี่ยเราบอกว่าเสียชีวิตขับถ้าแมว
หมาลิงใต้ตาละเนี่ยมรณภาพนะคะใช่ครับเป็น
คำที่ใช้กับพระสร้าง
กี่ปีแล้วเนาะ 3 หลายปีแล้วปี่มากผมคิด
ว่าน่าจะประมาณประมาณ 5 ปีขึ้นไปครับมา
ประมาณ 5 ปีขึ้นเป็นนี้ใช่ครับ
ก็มีต้องมีวัดของหลวงตามหาบัวใช่ตอนนี้
ถ้าไปที่วัดเนี่ยที่วัดก็จะมีเจดีย์
เจดีย์ที่บรรจุ
ก็ดูหลวงตามหาบัวไว้ในเช็ด
ใช่ครับหวัดดีเคยเข้าไปในคะอ่านี้อาทิก็
มีที่เจดีย์อันนี้เนี่ยเพิ่งสร้างเสร็จ
ใหม่ครับครัวที่ยังไม่เคยเข้าไปข้างใน
ครับแล้วที่วัดนะคะอาจ
ผู้เอนให้นะดูอะกูอ่ะดิคุยดูหนึ่งครั้ง
แรกคุยเกิดประเทศไทยหรือเปล่ามีหิมะตกเลย
ฮ่าๆๆเป็นสีขาวแล้วขาวอะไรได้ 4  5  V สี
เขียวสีดำเก๋กี่มาตกหรอเอาไปใช้นะคะ
ครับเพิ่งสร้างเสร็จใหม่ประมาณ 2-3 ปีที่
ผ่านมาเองครับถ้ายังใหม่ๆเลยครับก็เลย
เป็นสีที่สดใสอยู่นะครับขาวยังสวยอยู่
ครับ
อ้าโอเคไปไหว้พระก็แล้วไปไหว้หลวงตามหา
บัวเนี่ยเดี๋ยวพาไปเที่ยวต่อครับถ้าไป
เที่ยวที่ไหนอีกๆครับถ้าไม่ถึงที่อุดร
เนี่ยจะมีอีกที่หนึ่งเวลาพูดอุดรคนหรือจะ
คิดถึงที่นี่ครับที่ไหนเอ่ย We  Are ที่
ที่บ้านเชียงครับที่บ้านเชียงเนี่ยเป็น
มรดกโลกนะครับได้รับการขึ้นทะเบียนเป็น
บรมโลกเป็นสถานที่ที่เป็นประวัติศาสตร์
ของโลก
เพราะว่าที่เม็ดไม่ใช่ของไทยอ่ะ
มาระดกโลกขึ้นมรดกของประเทศไทยดังนั้น
อะไรดกของโลกหาของคนทั้งโลกชายครับ
เพราะว่าที่นี่เนี่ยเราเราขุดลงไปในดิน
อ่ะคุณแล้วไม่ได้แล้วเจอกับอะไร
เจอกับเครื่องปั้นดินเผาครับอ่าของของ
สมัยก่อนของสมัยก่อนประวัติศาสตร์ประมาณ
เขาบอกว่าเขาบอกว่าประมาณประมาณอ่ะ 5,000
กว่าปีงูให้อย่างนี้เราก็ต้องเรียกว่า
วัตถุโบราณ
เป็นวัดแต่โบราณได้ครับวัตถุโบราณจะเป็น
วัตถุโมรานที่เป็นเครื่องปั้นดินเผาๆมา
จากดินเผา
5,000 ปี Who นานมากเลยครับ 5,000 ปี
หรือคู่นาน
8 ใส่ยังสมบูรณ์อยู่เนาะอ้าก็มีบางส่วน
ที่ยังสมบูรณ์บางส่วนก็แตกแล้วเขาก็เอามา
ประกอบกันนะครับอ่ะท่อนเขาก็จะมีที่นี่
เขาก็จะมีพิพิธภัณฑ์ด้วยที่ประพันธ์บ้าน
เชียงก็สามารถเข้าไปนักท่องเที่ยวก็เข้า
ไปดูเอาไปศึกษาได้หรอเขามีอ่าเป็นอ่ะ
เครื่องปั้นดินเผาที่ใช่ทำอะไรบ้างนะครับ
มีลักษณะเป็นแบบไหนอะไรพูดตรงๆมรดกโลก
เนี่ยก็คือพิพิธภัณฑ์บ้านเชียงด้วยหรือ
เปล่าค่ายใช่ที่ประพันธ์บ้านเชียงเลยใช่
ครับทักเข้าไปข้างในเขาก็จะมี We  Are
หนักปากตัวอย่างสำหรับการขุดค้นอันนี้ก็
เป็นเป็นหุ่นนะครับไม่ใช่คนนะเป็นเป็น
หุ่นอ่าอาที่บอกว่าเขาเข้ามาศึกษาค้นคว้า
ขุดยังไงอ่ะให้กับเราเจออะไรบ้าง
เคยไปดูคนพี่เขาขุดเขาเรียกว่านัก
โบราณคดี
คนคนที่นักเรียนเห็นน่ะก็ต้องเรียกว่านัก
โบราณคดีนักโบราณคดีเวลาเข้าคุณต้องขุด
ที่รักที่รัก it ค่อยขุดครับ
ป่าป่าตินออกใช้เวลานานเนาะๆใช่ครับหือ
เพราะว่าทักขุดทีเดียวซึ่งเนี่ยของข้าง
ล่างจะเสียตายครับก็จะไปโดนไปโดนเครื่อง
ปั้นดินเผาก็จะแตกไปอีกนะครับก็เลยต้อง
ขุดเบาๆอุดช้าๆนะครับอ่าโอเคคะแล้วก็
สำหรับคนที่ไปท่องเที่ยวที่นี่แล้วชอบบาง
คนก็ชอบแจกันหรือว่าเครื่องปั้นดินเผาวัน
นี้แล้วก็จะมีข้างนอกนะข้างนอกก็จะมีขาย
เป็นเครื่องปั้นดินเผาที่ทำพันปีที่แล้ว
หรอไอ้ชัยอ่่ะไม่ใช่ของถูกใจพันปีนะครับ
ไม่ขายหรอกไม่ขายขายไม่ได้ก็จะมีอ่าอัน
นี้เป็นเป็นเรียนแบบ 5 ภัยครับคำทำให้
เหมือนกับของของเก่าแล้วก็เอามาขายค่ะ
สามารถซื้อกลับมาบ้านเอาไปใช้ได้ครับถ้า
ไม่ไม่มีอะไรตามมาอ่ะไม่มีครับเป็นของ
ใหม่ครับของใหม่นะครับขวดดีชอบเลยค่ะอ๋อ
กลัวแต่ชอบนะครับชอบมีไหมคะซื้อมาไว้ที่
บ้านบ้างนะไม่ได้ซื้อมาครับหน้าเพราะว่า
ปกติแล้วถ้าซื้อเป็นกระถางเมื่อกี้ก็จะ
ซื้อเป็นกระถางต้นไม้นะครับค่ะดาธรรมดา
เอามาปลูกหน้าบ้านก็ราคาไม่แพงมากถ้าทำ
แต่ก็ไม่ถ้าทำแต่ก็ไม่เสียใจแต่ถ้าแบบนี้
ลายสวยปลูกต้นไม้แล้วแต่ก็เสียใจว่ะตี้
อันเนี้ยอันอยู่ข้างหน้าเลยเนี่ยอันไหน
ครับอันนี้ปาร์ตี้ที่อยู่นะคะถามไม่ใส่
น้ำใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอ่ะใช่ครับหาลักษณะนิสัย
น้ำครับถ้ามีบ้านบ้านไทยๆเนาะแล้วก็มี
องค์เล็กๆๆๆครับก็ใส่น้ำหนาวนึกว่าข้างบน
ฝาแถวที่ 2 จะมีที่ตักน้ำหน้านี่ครับนี่
จะมีที่ตักน้ำอยู่ตรงนี้และก็ตัดแล้วก็
ดื่มนะใช้งับสมัยโบราณนะครับสมัยโบราณเรา
ก็ใช้ที่ตักน้ำแบบนี้ค่ะ
สวยเนาะถ้า
แพงไม่ทำ what  it จำราคาไม่ได้แล้วครับ
ตอนจังตอนนั้นต่อไปน่าจะประมาณ 3-4 ร้อย
ครับ
ใส่ครับแต่ตอนนี้อาจจะแพงขึ้นกว่านี้อีก
แล้วลายสวยค่ะลายสุดครับผม
โอเคไปที่พิพิธภัณฑ์บ้านเชียงใช่ครับปั้น
ดินเผาขายค้าได้ครับเดี๋ยวพาไปต่อกันที่
วัดอีกวัดนึงครับไว้อะไรคะวัดนี้เนี่ยวัด
นี้นี่อยู่บนภูเขา
โอเคเห็นรูปในอินเตอร์เน็ตบ่อยมากอ๋ออ๋อ
เหรอครับกำลังคิดว่าอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่ที่
อุดรนี่เองคือคุยชอบวันนี้มากอ่ะแต่ไม่
รู้สึกอะไรนะคะนั้นชอบตรงไหนครับชอบที่
เป็นสีฟ้าอ๋อใช่ชอบอยู่
วิวสวย
อยู่บนภูเขาใช่ไหมเพราะปกติแล้ววัดเนี่ย
วัดทั่วไปที่เห็นในประเทศไทยก็จะมีสีแดง
ใช่มั้ยใช่เหรียญทองค่ะมีสีขาวแต่วัดนี้
วัดวิธีฟ้า
ซ้าย
ไม่เคยเห็นเลยนะคะว่าสีฟ้าครับผมวัดนี้
ชื่อวัดป่าภูก้อนครับ
บ้างอยู่ในสร้างอยู่ในเป็นป่าสงวนนะครับ
ค่ะพื้นที่ป่าสงวนไม่ได้เป็นบ้านคนนะครับ
รอบจะเป็นเอ่อปากอะไรคือห้ามตัดต้นไม้ๆ
ครับนั่งทำบ้านๆห้องน้ำหญิงนกอาหารหมา
เป็นของอ่าของราชการครับไม่ใช่ของประชาชน
ใช่นะหาของประเทศไทยอ่ะอ่ากุประเทศไทยได้
ครับอ้าแล้วเออต่อสิ่งพิเศษอีกอย่างหนึ่ง
อะไรคะอันนี้เนี่ยอ่าสร้างด้วยหินอ่อนงูๆ
หินอ่อนจากอิตาลีด้วยแข่งมาแทงมากใจหรอ
ใครสร้างเก็บถามทำไมอ๋อ
นึกว่ามีปกติแล้ววัดใหญ่ๆสวยๆในประเทศไทย
ก็จะมีคนที่
นับถือในศาสนาพุทธได้ก็จะช่วยกันบริจาค
เงินค่ะหาแล้วช่วยกันสร้างวัดเรียกว่าทำ
บุญทำบุญตั้งวัดแฟนทำค่ะกูอะตีรวัฒน์นี้
นะอยู่บนภูเขาเวลาจะไปเนี่ย
ต้องเดินขึ้นหรือขับรถขึ้นมาอันนี้เนี่ย
ทันสมัยแล้วก็สามารถขับรถขึ้นไปขับรถเคส
ซอยใจหาด้านหน้าวัดแล้วก็เดินขึ้นไปที่
วัดได้ครับหายใจ
เองไม่ชอบเดินนักเรียน
หาตัวเองเดินขึ้นไปเดี๋ยวก็เห็นหลับเลยขอ
ขับรถขึ้นไม่ได้ก็มีโอกาสใช่ไหมครับมี
โอกาสว่าจะได้ไปนะโอเคข้างในครับครับมี
อะไรคะนายอ่ะข้างในมีพระพุทธรูปครับพระ
พุทธรุปกไก่ทำจากหินอ่อนเหมือนกันครับ
5 เดี๋ยวพาเขาไปดูครับนี่ครับนี่เดี๋ยว
นะกินอ่อนสีขาวหรือสีฟ้าหรือสิขาวครับอ๋อ
แต่ตอนนี้เปิดเป็นตอนกลางคืนแล้วเขาเปิด
ไฟเป็นสีฟ้าอ้าเป็นพระพุทธรูปอ่ะพระ
พุทธรูปเนี่ยเราจะเรียกเป็นปางนะคะอ้าปาง
ปางทิพย์จะยืนหรือว่านั่งก็ต้องปางนั่ง
สมาธิชาย
ห้ามญาติมหาก็คืนนี้ก็เป็นปลาปางใส่หรือ
เปล่าใส่หญ้าคืนนอนน่านอนอยู่ใช่ครับ
องค์ใหญ่มากนะองค์ใหญ่มากครับขนาดของความ
ยาวของพระพุทธรูปองค์นี้ก็ยาวประมาณ 20
เมตรคู่ 20 เมตรครับ 10 เมตรหรอตายครับ
เทียบจากเมื่อวานนี้ก็จะจะจัดด้านนี้ถึง
ด้านนี้เลยครับ
อยู่ในอาคารหลังใหญ่นี่เลยครับโอ้ 20 นาย
ครับ 5 ยาว 20 เมตรที่เคยไปในคะที่นี่มาก
กว่าที่ยังไม่เคยไปเหมือนกันอยากไปใช่ไหม
คะความไม่นักเรียนดูอาหารใช้ครับวันี้
เพิ่งสร้างเสร็จสร้างเสร็จประมาณ 10 ปี
ที่แล้วเองครับค่า
จ้างต่อคนที่สร้างตั้งใจสร้างให้ให้เพื่อ
ถวายกับในหลวงรัชกาลที่ 9 อ้าๆนะฮะอ่อน
ฉลองครบที่ในหลวงครบรอบ 84 อายุ 84 พรรษา
ใช้ครับ
น่าสนใจครับสวยมากครับสวยสวยนะคะมีโอกาส
ไปนะคะอุดรยังไม่เคย
แล้วก็ชอบกะวัดนี้นะคะสีสวยมากครับอยู่บน
ภูเขา
แล้วที่วัดนี้นี่เน็ตส่งไหมคะอ้าวัดนี้
ไม่มีพระสงฆ์ครับ
ว่า
ก๊อตจิกินในเมืองไทยนักเรียนจะมีวัดบาง
วัดที่จะไม่มีพระสงฆ์ถามนะไปเช่นวัด
พระแก้วในกรุงเทพฯก็ไม่มีพระสงฆ์ค่ะถาม
น่ะตัวเองดูแลเอกกูเองก็รู้สึกว่าน่าจะ
ไม่มีพระใช่ครับเพราะว่ามีแต่วิหารมีแต่
เจดีย์ที่เก็บอาบครับพุทธรูปแล้วก็เก็บ
พวกอ่าเรียกว่าอะไรครับนั้นไปปิฎกหรอคะ
ที่เก็บกระดูกเรียกว่าอะไรนะครับ
เจดีย์เก็บพระบรมสารีริกธาตุ
ใช่ใช่ๆเท่านั้นใช้งับเพราะว่าเป็นพื้น
ที่ของป่าสงวนหามีพระอยู่พระจะได้ต้องออก
ไปบิณฑบาตแล้วรอบๆมีแต่ภูเขาก็บิณฑบาตร
ไม่ได้พี่เดินไกลมาก
ได้ครับหือโอเคสวยจังเลยสวยครับเป็นสีฟ้า
สวยอยู่บนภูเขาครับอ้าเดี๋ยวต่อไปครับไป
จะไปไหนไปอีกที่นึงครับไปที่อ่า
เดี๋ยวนะเราเรียกว่าทะเลเป็นทะเลแต่เป็น
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่น้ำเค็มนะเพราะว่าอุดรเนี่ย
อุดรเนี่ยไม่ติดทะเลนั่นน่ะสิอ่าไปทะเลกู
เองอามีทะเลสาบอยู่ที่อุดรค่ะเป็นทะเล 3
จืดค่าๆครับที่นี่ครับจะมีดอกบัวหัวอ่า
เรียกว่าทะเลบัวแดงทะเลบัวแดงไม่ครับบัว
แดงเนี่ยถ้าดูใกล้ๆเนี่ยก็จะเห็นว่ามัน
เป็นสีแดงครับนี่สิริแดงสีชมพูสีโอเคสิ
อย่าเพิ่งออกสีชมพูนะแต่ไงอ่ะเป็นสีชมพู
เข้มเข้มว่าแดงคนไทยก็เลยเรียกว่าสีแดง
อ่ะเป็นสีชมพูเข้มนะครับอ่ะตรงกลางที่
เป็นเกสรเขาว่าจะออกแดงอาจาร์ยต้องเกสรจะ
เป็นสีแดงเหลือแต่กรีบกรีดดอกเนี่ยจะเป็น
สีชมพูแกครับก็เขาเรียกบัวแดงจะบ้านพี่
น่ะเรียกบัวสายขอทรายๆๆบ้านครัวตี้ก็
เรียกบัวสายเหมือนกันน่าน่าถามพ่อก็ทำ
เป็นแหล่งท่องเที่ยวเขาก็เรียกบัวแดงถ้า
ไม่พูดบัวชมพูณ
วันนี้กูเอกก็ติดทำไมทำคือไม่เรียบวัว
ชมพูเพราะว่าสีแดงเป็นสีโชคดีอ่ะ
มีค่าเลย
โอเคก็คิดชื่อเขาว่าเป็นบัวแดงกลัวแต่
บ้านเราเนี่ยบัวซ้ายกินได้ไหมคะขออัดมี
แต่เนี่ยอ้าบัวสายเนี่ยเราไม่กินดอกค่ะ
อ้าเราจะกินอะสายของบัวก้านบัวเล็กกว่า
การบัวมหาไฟเบอร์สูงอาไซครับแต่บางคนก็
เรียกสายวัวใช่ไหมคนไทยส่วนใหญ่จะเรียก
สายบัวไอ้บูว่าสั้นกินได้กินอะไรกูจะเป็น
เป็นทั้งทะเลสาบเลยนะคะๆครับเป็นทั้ง
สเปย์ 3 ว่างใหญ่กว้างไกลเลยครับงาน
กี่ไร่หาตรงนี้เนี่ยพื้นที่พื้นที่ประมาณ
2 หมื่น 2,000 บาท 500 ไร่ครับ
ว่างมากหมอออกไปก็ไอมากเลยเอาของคืออัน
นี้ของใครอ่ะ
เป็นอ่ะเป็นของของเป็นพื้นที่ของจังหวัด
ครับไม่ได้มีเจ้าของได้ครับอ่า
เข้าไปน่ะฟรีไหมคะหรือต้องจ่ายเงินต้อง
จ่ายเงินค่าเรือครับเพราะหมอเขาว่ายน้ำไป
ไม่ได้ไม่ใช่แค่เราไปแล้วแต่เราไม่ลงเรือ
เราดูอยู่เฉยๆอ๋อเข้าไปได้ครับเข้าไปฟรี
ครับแต่ถ้าเราจะอ่ะนั่งเรือแล้วเข้าไปดู
ใกล้ๆหัวอาหารก็จะมีเรือรับจ้างแบบนี้
ครับมีเรือลำเล็กลำใหญ่ไปได้หลายๆคนก็มี
สิทธิ์คน 15 คน 20 คนห้าคนก็ไปได้ถ้าไม่
ค้า 1 คนเท่าไหร่อ่ะเหมาเป็นรำใช่นำเหมา
เป็นรำครับตอนล่ำราคาก็จะอยู่ประมาณ
150-300 บาทครับอ้าไม่แพงไม่แพงใช้เวลา
ประมาณ
45 นาทีหรือ 1 ชั่วโมงก็มองดูรอบๆขับ
เรือไปตามอ่าในทะเลบัวแดงนี้ครับหน้าไป
ค่ะแต่ถ้าไปเนี่ยต้องไว้ตอนเช้านะ
ๆไม่ได้ฮ่าๆๆไม่ได้นะชิมดึงไม่ได้ครับ
เพราะว่ายังไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ที่สาธารณะที่ที่
จะดึงเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวก็จะมีคนอื่นมาดูเอา
ดอกบัวหายไปไหนหมดทุกคนมาเก็บวัวหมดเลย
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ตัวเองสงสัยไงว่าไอ้เอ๋เห็น
แล้วก็อยากจะกินก็ดึงได้ไหมคะขอไม่ได้
ครับไปได้ครับกว่าตี้ปเมื่อกี้กว่าตีบอก
ว่าน้องไปตอนเช้าทำให้อ่ะทำไมเหรอครับหา
ว่าดอกบัวเนี่ยดอกบัวจะบานบ้านตอนไหนครับ
ตอนเช้าค่ะค่ายเดี๋ยวกูจะบานตอนเช้าแล้ว
พอประมาณสักอ่าอีกโมง 10 โมงอ่ะบวกก็จะ
เริ่มคู่ปุกและบ๊ายบายอื้อคือคือนักเรียน
บัวแดงมีความน่ารักตรงนี้ค่ะบานแล้วก็หุๆ
กับขบวนบางชนิดนะบานแล้วก็บานเลยใต้บ้าน
แล้วก็บานเลยแล้วก็ร่วงดวง
นั้นเรียกบัวหลวงครับที่กลัวตีเคยพาไปดู
หน้าที่ที่ประจวบจำได้ไหมจะหน้าที่ไปเขา
แดงที่ไปดู
ที่ดูนกที่มีบัวหลวงนั้นจะบานครั้งเดียว
บายแล้วบานเลยวัวแดงเนี่ยบานแล้วก็คุก
เหมือนเมื่อกี้ไปเมื่อกี้กูเอาตีก็มีภาพ
บัวหลวงใช่ครับมีบัวหลวงนี่ครับถ้า
บัวหลวงจะเป็นแบบนี้นักเรียนจะเคยเห็นบัว
หลวงตอนที่เขาเอามาไหว้พระเยอะใช่ไหมครับ
เหนื่อยที่วัดนี้จะเป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
บัวหลวงบานแล้วไม่หุบบ้านแล้วไม่ห่วงครับ
เพราะว่าครูเอกเคยไปดูที่สวนในกรุงเทพฯก็
มีดอกบัวก็กูเอกก็เห็นว่าหลวงก็บ้าแล้วก็
มานั้นก็ได้
ครับแต่ว่าดอกบัวหลวงเนี่ยเวลาบานแล้วเขา
จะมีเขาจะมีฝักอยู่ข้างในบิ๊กกินได้กิน
ฝักได้ค่ะๆๆๆ
การบัวหลวงกินได้ไหมคะก้านบัวหนูกินไม่
ได้ได้ผู้แต่งว่าให้ใส่ครับแต่เราเรากิน
รากมันหึงล่างของบัวหลวงค่ะ 5 โอเคกูว่า
นะๆเป็นรากบัวดีกับสุขภาพค่ะรักบัวฝักบัว
ก็ดีกับสุขภาพใต้ฝักบัวก็เอามาทำขนมไทย
หลายๆอย่างก็ใส่เม็ดบัวหา OD กับหวยเขาทำ
เป็นยาด้วยนะ
ครับ
Happy  shop ไหมคะอ่ะผมชอบกินเม็ดบัวมาก
กว่าไปครับพี่ชอบกินรากบัว
โอเคบัวแดงหน้าไปนะฮะอะไรครับอยู่ที่
อุดรธานีนะครับไปเที่ยววัดแล้วก็ไปเที่ยว
ทะเลบัวแดงกันด้วยนะครับแล้วมีอะไรอีกไหม
คะมีอีกครั้งหนึ่งนะครับอีกที่หนึ่งก่อน
ที่จะหมดเวลาเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้จะพาไปนี่ครับ
อ๋อป้ามีการประมงก็มาหาปลาครับอ๋อได้ค่ะ
มีค่ะมีมือหนักปลาอยู่ในเรือ
อ๋อเพราะว่าเป็นทะเลสาบตายพื้นที่ฝากมาก
ครับโอเคอ้าไปกันที่นี่อีกทีน่ะกูเหรอชอบ
ที่นี่หรือเคยได้ยินที่นี่แล้วแน่ๆเลยที่
นี่ครับมีต้นไม้มีสนานมีพวงมาลัย
ที่มีอันไหนเป็น
จ๋าหน้าตาอันนี้เป็นต้นไม้แล้วก็มีผ้าผ้า
สีแผ่อาแปสีสีนะครับรถพวงมาลัย
มีบันไดด้วยบันไดขึ้นศาลนะครับเล็กๆคน
ขึ้นไม่ได้นะคะ 3 คนขึ้นไม่ได้อ้าวหรอที่
พูดไว้เมื่อกี้ก็ต่อคะ
อาทิใช่ครับที่นี่เขาบอกว่าเป็นที่ที่
เป็นประตูประตูรับสู่เมืองไปเมืองบาดาล
ที่มีที่พญานาคอยู่ออกไปอ่าช่ายๆครับอื้อ
คำชะโนดครับเกาะคำชะโนดหาและส่วนใหญ่คน
ที่ไปที่นี่ไม่ได้ไปหาพญานาคนะครับเอ้าไป
หาอะไรอ่ะไปขอไปขอเลขเลขเด็ดๆครับ
สลีย์
เคยไว้ขอขอให้ธุรกิจดีๆนะคะกู Arty กับกู
เองก็จะไปไหว้แล้วก็บอกว่าขอให้มีนัก
เรียนเยอะๆดีครับเพื่อนมากดไลค์
ขอให้นักเรียนเรียนภาษาไทยกันเยอะๆนะครับ
ง่ายมากจะได้รู้จักประเทศไทยมากขึ้นนะ
ครับอ่าโอเคนะพี่ก็แม่ที่คำชะโนดออกอ๋อ
วันที่เคยไปนะคะที่คำชะโนดครัวเต็มไม่เคย
ไม่เคยแวะเข้าไปอ่า
แต่ปกติควรตีก็ไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อลอตเตอรี่
อยู่แล้วแล้วก็เลยคิดว่าก็ไม่รู้จะไปทำไม
เอกก็อยากไปสักหนึ่งครั้งนะคะไม่ได้ไปขอ
ล็อตเตอรี่นะคะนักเรียนตัวเองอยาก
ไปดูอะไรไม่รู้ก็อยากดูอยากรู้ว่าเขาไปทำ
อะไรกันเลยอยากจะดูว่าเขาทำอะไรกันที่
คำชะโนดอากาศเป็นยังไงนะคะ
ที่นี่เนี่ยปกติคนก็จะไปกันเยอะในวันที่
วันที่ 30 วันที่ 15 ใช่ครับคนทำอะไรเยอะ
ค่ะ
หน้านี่นี่ต้นนี้ครับตอนนี้ตอนคำชะโนดต้น
ชะโนดครับนี่คือต้นชะโนดค่ะเพิ่งชะโนดใน
ก็จะมีลักษณะข้นสูงอายุดูเท่าดูต้นชะโนด
ไกลๆเนี่ยเราก็จะคิดว่าเอ๊ะมันเหมือนต้น
ตาลช่อซ้ายติดตั้งแต่ดูไกลๆเหมือนต้นตาม
แต่ทิศลำต้นเนี่ยลำต้นเนี่ยจะคล้ายๆต้น
ปาล์มครับขอหน้าออกขึ้นป่ายปีนขึ้นไปได้
แล้วลูกลูกของลูกชะโนดเนี่ยจะเหมือนกับ
แม่นอะไรมากนอนกินได้ไหม ahh กินได้ครับ
อยู่ได้ด้วย
เหมือนหมากจากคุณจะกล้ากินไหมคะเป็นหยุด
มากินนะฮ่าๆๆว่าคือที่กูแอบถามเนี่ย
เนื่องจากเกาะคำชะโนดน่ะเรามีความเชื่อ
ว่าเป็นประตูเป็นมีบ่อน้ำหมอนะครับดีบอก
ดูสำหรับพญานาคพญานาคนะคะอ่าอ่า
สวัสดีไม่มีรูปคะอย่างลากไหมฮะไม่มีนารูป
พญานาคที่คำชะโนดกลัวแต่ไม่มีครับน้อคือ
จะมีพญานาคเนี่ยขึ้นมานะครับพญานาคเนี่ย
ก็เหมือนๆงูนะคะแต่ว่าจะเดี๋ยว
มีงอนได้ไหมมีหงอนเอ้อ
ก็บางคลิปของเราก็จะพูดเกี่ยวกับพญานาคก็
แล้วเนาะหน้านี่กูเองหมายถึงว่าคนก็จะคิด
ว่าเองอ่ะลูกของชะโนดเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นผลไม้
สัก 10 ก็เลยคนก็จะไม่กล้าอิ่มกลายเป็น
ของพญานาคหรือเปล่าคนไม่กล้าเก็บว่ะมามาร
นั้น
โหจะสวยค่ะก็อ่าใช่ครับก็คือวงที่กู Arty
พาไปดู
เข้าไปที่นักเรียนจะเห็นเลยค่ะมีมีอะไรนะ
อาจจะมีพญานาคๆอยู่ที่อ่างเดินนะครับสอง
ข้างทางจะมีรูปปั้นพญานาคอยู่ได้ไหม
โอเคโอเคโอหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมค่ะใช่ครับ
หมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยววันนี้เราพาไปที่
อุดรธานีนะครับมีหลายๆที่ที่น่าสนใจแล้ว
กับมันหมดเวลาและแต่ถ้ามีโอกาสเดี๋ยวเขา
หน้าเรามาเล่าให้ฟังนะครับค่ะพัฒนเกรียน
มาเมืองไทยไม่รู้จะไปที่ไหนก็ลองไปเที่ยว
อุดรดูนะคะเราไปเที่ยวดอนน่าสนใจๆใช่ครับ
ถ้าโอเคอ้าวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวเอา
ครัวเตี้ยกูพี่่ต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับเดี๋ยว
ขับมาเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้าเราจะพาไปเที่ยว
ที่ไหนเดี๋ยวค่อยติดตามกันนะครับถ้าครับ
ผมวันนี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะโอเคอ่าอ่ะ
[เพลง]